janisch walter und ich sind heute in
berlin
wir wollen euch zeigen wie man in einem
deutschen kaffee einen kaffee bestellt
los geht's
die frage ist wenn du in einem café ist
in deutschland ja und du willst einen
kaffee bestellen was sagt sogar ich
hätte gern einen cappuccino oder ein
café ich hätte gerne einen kaffee mit
milch
ich hätte gerne einen kaffee ich hätte
gerne einen kaffee gibt es noch einen
anderen satz den er benutzen könnte ein
café latte bitte ein café bitte einmal
kino bitte einen kaffee bitte und gibt
es noch eine variante dass zusagen
könnte ich bitte einen kaffee haben
jaja könnte ich bitte ein café haben
könnte ich bitte einen kaffee bekommen
und wie sieht's aus mit ich bekomme
einen kaffee
das will ich ja nicht sagen warum nicht
das klingt so ein bisschen altbacken
findest du das selber als unhöflich ja
also es nicht so gut das ist so würde
ich nicht machen als du angefangen hast
deutsch zu lernen
hast du auch manchmal das falsch gesagt
wenn ich dran nee spaß gemacht ja
vielleicht schon habe ich einmal gesagt
ich möchte die cappuccino und was ist
daran falsch
ich möchte cappuccino ich kann es nicht
erklären
ja ein bisschen unhöflich sowie auf
englisch warnte cappuccino ich das sagt
man nicht in einem café und wie ist es
mit maxxim ihren kaffee trinkt nicht so
oft café ja nicht so oft in kaffee als
dass ich sie in jähnigen so gut kennen
würde dass ich das so sagen würde also
das sagt man wenn man schon bekannten
bekanntesten sagst du manchmal auch ich
nehme im café aber ich arbeite auch
selber einem café deswegen
ich weiß dass es möglich sein soll aber
das ist perfekt dann kannst du uns
vielleicht noch sagen wie kann man denn
unhöflich fragen oder was ist unhöflich
in deutschland ein café wird es schon
unhöflich ja vielleicht schon wieso da
einen kaffee ich nehme meinen kaffee
nicht mit bitte das bitte muss weg und
passiert es manchmal dass menschen weil
die reinkommen sagen ich nehme kaffee da
klar immer ich hätte gerne einen kaffee
oder ein café wird also ja deutsche sind
oft unmöglich definitiv aber nicht nur
deutsche menschen nur die sagen jetzt
ist es soweit wir bestellen ich selbst
einen kaffee wir haben wir euch ja viel
gefunden los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo also ich hätte gerne ein
cappuccino und einen tee auch ein
früchtetee
nun da ist bestimmt gut ja ja wohl unter
ist lecker und dann hätte gerne eine
waffe mit kirschen
unbedingt dazu ich hätte gern einen
schwarzen kaffee bitte
[Musik]
alter jetzt bist du dran ich hätte gerne
eine fische
danke danke
die
während walter und janisch die waffel
verschwinden verabschiede ich mich von
euch ihr könnt jetzt noch weiter easy
gemen unterstützen zum beispiel dann
bekommt ihr jede woche übungen zu
unserem vokabular
ja ich möchte euch segnen sie sehen dass
er auch abonnieren können
das nennt er die klingel und wenn ihr
auf die klingel klickt unter unserem
kanal dann bekommt er immer eine
nachricht können wir ein neues siegel
draußen haben wir hoffen dass das video
auch euch geholfen hat und dass wir
jetzt demnächst kaffee in deutschland
selber bestellen könnt dankeschön fürs
zuschauen und bis zur nächsten woche
binya